vieira cartes et pour la une au au
pardon désolé pour le café mais je vous
rassure ce n'est pas une question
d'agilité c'est juste une question de
mouches l'abus d'alcool est dangereux
pour la santé à consommer avec
modération
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si la mousse colle aux lèvres et à la
moustache
elle colle aussi ouvert et c'est ça qui
empêche le liquide de déborder ce sont
deux physiciens français qui en
apportent la preuve en images là on voit
un liquide sont mus et là avec sa petite
mousse protectrice et vous pouvez même
faire l'expérience chez vous à la maison
amateurs de bière comme de café mais
aussi fort en maths
nos chercheurs ont réussi à trouver les
équations physique qui décrivent ce
phénomène cela leur a permis de montrer
que les bulles en se frottant contre la
paroi dissipe l'énergie du mouvement
bref plus il ya de bulles - ça tangue
mais attention pas la peine non plus de
trop en rajouter dans leur tasse
rectangulaire très chic au demeurant les
chercheurs ont montré que sa couche de
bulles suffisait à réduire le
débordement d'un facteur 10 bon
j'entends déjà celles et ceux qui vont
dire que la science pourrait servir à
des choses plus utiles que la moux de la
bière ou du café et bien sachez que la
maîtrise de la mousse pourrait permettre
de sécuriser des transports de matières
dangereuses comme le gaz liquide ou le
carburant de fusée en ajoutant une
petite couche protectrice sur ces
liquides sensible aux chocs
on pourrait éviter la catastrophe et
bien voilà un petit zeste de sciences a
raconté en soirée si vous voulez vous
faire mousser
et voilà abonne toi